ha
re
me
t
今日はクイズを出す楽器の山からもありました
えっと秋のヤマハの研究上からまあきたわけですけれども
うちの山の形愛としてはですね
楽器と音響機器の製造がだいたいしな
形はになっておりまして好都合上研究所の仕事もそういった楽器と環境基金ですね
ために必要な技術開発
そういうところになっています私はそこにいまして
8通称ケイズラボって呼ばれてるんですよ僕の研究室みたいなチームを持っておりまし
て
まあの頃汲みに行ってるんですけれども
その話を今日はされてい
タイトルにあるように音の絵
音作りのですねあるボーイズとそれをデジタルでやってるんですがその話をさせて
いただきます
8その前にですね私の幼少時代が足中から始めさせていただきたいんですが
私山のんが教室でエレクトーン幼稚園小学校となってました
でまぁ5年ぐらいやったら時期もうちょっと飽きちゃったですね嫌になって辞めちゃっ
たんですけども
逆に止めるとそっからまあ好きな音楽をやるっていうのが楽しくなっちゃっ woody
a もうにょピアノ弾いたり
シンセ際だーを引いたりというお定まりのコースにはまっていたわけです
で応答とや友人とバンドを組んであちこちで桜演奏したいとそんなことをやっており
ました
でその一方でですね電子工作の趣味をやっておりまして
え
えっと
まあ音や音楽が大好きなものですから当然な塩とかそういったものが中心なんですけど
まぁ音の出る電子工作をいろいろやってい
当時はですねまぁまだトランジスター真空管の時代終わってたんですけどだいたい何時
スターみたいだったんですのようなトランジスターのラジオの工作なんかをたくさん
やってました
で大学にすんなんですけれども大学に行って研究室あのコンピューター系の研究室に
するなんですね
まてぃうでそうするとこんないわゆるマイコンという呼び方を投じされていたんですが
色々なこーぎ番号部品を組んだ
手作りのコンピューターがたくさん研究室では稼働しておりました
それ
そのコンピューターですねマイコンという場合コンピューターでデータを集めて処理を
して
またなんか結果を出すというようなことをいろいろするんですが画像の信号所員みたい
なことが
もたったところでしたでもまぁその画像をですもう個人的にはちょっと六足らないもの
ですからまあ音に使える信号
周囲というところに何な研究の分野をシフトしていったという
妙な感じの収支の時代でした
一方でプラ部活動の方ですけれどもクラブ活動はですね
こういう自作のオーディオ機器を作るというクラブをやってまして
レコードを聴くんですけれどもプレイヤーをつくっており用アンプをつくって
スピーカーをつくってとそんなことをやっていたと
0そうするとあのまあいろいろまあ音の成り立ち中の被害と
c 議員をですね回路だけじゃんくてぃぶひーまんだーとか色々な学びがありました
で8もう一つの子ですねまあをとうとうとかを自分の板東をやっているわけですが
バンドをやってるそこの機材が必要になってくるんですけれども
その機材というのを相当する自分で作っておりました
それが面白かったしお金もないですからねまあ自分ですけどお金も助かるとこのころは
もうするですそれもこれ
でもアナログの全盛時代ですから
今みたいにデジタル両党をなすということはなくてアナログのパーツトランジスタとか
抵抗含んでやるとそうするとそういったものをその組んで何か開花交錯してというのは
もう玩具のように扱っていたえええ
という感じですねそれが高じるとですねこういうことを初めてまして
8雑誌に記事を投稿するということをしてました
音楽雑誌というかロック雑誌 rock 誌に8
弟や自分のために作った機材を
製作記事にして投稿する
そんなことをやっていた大学時代です
8で倉庫してうちに修士卒業となりまして
1982年に山入りました
で入るとですねええ
会えなんですよ
まったくもってその80年頃にガラッとこう世の中変わる時代がでだいたいその頃にに
cd プレーヤーも出たわけですね cd とし
ですから山の社外でもを等を扱うし信号処理がアナルんからあの
デジタル cpu ダディスピードである
a サイトそういったものにガーとこうカール
激動の時代にが者入ったとで自分そういうものをその大学で体感してましたし
デジタルアナログ両方とも音作りはまあまあ
見つけ出していた頃ということでまぁいいタイミングで会社に入れたなと
にアナログの音作りのある多い相撲デジタルの音作りないボーイズにこう転換していく
という
ところに自分の注文があったものですからいいタイミングで
ような感じられたら的
おります
でデジタルでの音作りない応じてどんなことが載っていうのちょっとご説明させて
ください
えーと何がわかりやすいかなと思ったんですが
エレキギターの音加工してすねィダンプ唐櫃が乗っているような感じを出すそういう
アナログの音作りをデジタルのこと作りで a
アルゴリズムでこう再現するという一連の手続きに今こちらで
がお聞かせしますまず二番最初にです a キー母のもと
プラグから音が上げた状態ですねえれー聞いたを耳でこうそのままその場で聞くという
ことじゃなくて
エレギターのプラグから来音が出て行くとプラグケーブルをさせたところか
出てくるとそのまんま覚醒して流します
あっはぁんっ
マッハ
ということですねでこれにですねまずスピーカーんとスピーカーキャビネット
ギターアンプ飲むというスピーカースピーカーキャビネットの冒頭のその高いよ途中
くらいノート-8との共同分布を与えます
その共同文法周波数特性という形を技術的には進んですがこれで言うと高い周波数中域
の子はステーキの白それぞれの音量がこういうカーブでプロされてるんですねそうする
と高い方はもう
たら朝日あ中域事
冬のピークがあってこれはスピーカーとかスピーカーキャビネットの共振がこういう
郷土のピックをつくって2も家の鍵も大和た気が相まって音色をみなさんですねそう
いったものをちゃんと再現してやると
ということでそれを先ほどの a キーだんって言いますかけます
あっはーん
あああああああ
ブーブー言うの
動作点って言うんですけど難しタムというのは四川形成月非常に強くてですね
音量も入れますが歪むんですねその歪みというようなギターアンプみんなそれぞれにお
湯ですしそれが
中のデバイスに接続時にしていますちょっと今日はモデリングですんです非常に簡単な
音作りでご提示します
par
ana
ああああああ
こういう数になってくるとだんだんロックっぽくなるんですかちょっと耳みたいなこと
ですよね
英語でハーシュって言うんですけど
この状態じゃあまだまだですただ先ほどの周波数特性ですねこれと今の歪んの両方を
掛け合わせると
同人やるた敵をするとですねかなりボックポートアーサーああっ
あっはぁああ
me
で実際のギターアンプというのはですねその歪みとし周波数特性というのは何重にも
駅員もかかっています
ブリ団でも大きいのあのそういう歪みを知らせ特製ありますし
行く文8トーンコントロール弾でも気付かパワーアンプのところでも大きいから
スピーカーんところでも知らせ特性だけして一陣もきますで4
10ぐらいかかるんですねそれを全部やったのがやると商品になるんですけど今日は
商品で本当にお聞かせします
ani
はっはっはっはっはー
me
こんな感じで帰りロックなどになったと思うんですけどこれはの本当に家の売ってる
商品の音でして
ええまあちょっと実験室的にその前半は行ってましたけど最後はもう
売り物として調整済みの状態ですがさすがにいい音です
であのこうやってアナログの時代の機材真空管のようなものですねそういったものを
アナログのある個人か翻訳してデジタルノートづくりのある52転換してデジタルで
紅葉とを鳴らしているというのがうちの会社
の商品でもあるわけでまあ他社でもそういうものがありますがまあ正直市の会社のが
一番効率は高いと思っています
実際コアなファンの方にあの大きい支持をいただいているところですね来られれば
こんなことでアナル軍に版があなたにも版があるんじゃないですね
アナログの時代の音をデジタルの音作りになり法人を再現するというなエディターが別
だよ
唯一者があります実際にはいろんなものがあります例えばこれはあの山の昔の入れ p
電気ピアノですけど他社の天気いろいろございますこういったものもそういった
アナログの音作りをデジタル
の音付くなら5 u 変換してえおとづとしていかないとなかなかいい音になる僕は
どっちかというとご説明したようにピアノとか
新生剤が効いてたクチですがこちらの方がむしろこういったものの得意分野です
でそのいうことをですねあの上手にやっていくためには真空管等のトランジスター
といったデバイスを
細かいところまで開設しあるところは測定してですね
アナログのもので自体に転換していくということが非常に大事になります
してそうするとアナログのアホ届いが悪くジョンアルゴリズム予定地たるに
のアルゴリズムを転換しするだけだしたらデジタル得意のものというの要素という色々
他にもありはありますからそういったものを組み合わせながら新しい価値観が出てくる
と
要するにまあ一周温故知新をすることにあるんですね
a 棟をこのようにです7分の時代中の基盤にいこうとこういうトランジスターとか
抵抗とかっていうのを実装して版画で
アルゴリズムを組んでいたですねそれが今はデジタルでるんねやりますから当然その
ベース p とか cpu とかそういった ds 信号処理をするような
ハードウェア無碍のソフ
からコード a
どちらかというとパソコンの上で書いてる形になりますですからやってることが同じだ
けれどもやたら昔はパーツで天気変えるパーティーをやっていたことが今
コンピューターのソフトウェアで
やっていると2が違うそうすると使うツールというような多くの部分は
macintosh の os 上のものだったら windows 上の
するだったらまあいろいろするんですけれどもツールがあったけどもやっていることは
そして新しいプラットフォームじゃあたし価値観を生み出して
様子に大河内身をすることなんですね古いものを除いて
古いものを温ねて新しきを知るというあのこっち c という言葉ですけれどもそれを
毎日会ってるのが私たちの仕事です
まあそういった形でやるものですから越前とですね新しいプラットフォーム上の
いろんななんていうメリットというもの逆に取り込むことになりますが
えーとこれはデジタルの得意技というのですねちょっと並べてみたんですけどみなさん
ほとんどの方がスマホを持っていてでたくさん写真を撮ってそれをメモリーにセーブし
てい車
ですねあるいはたくさんの楽曲をスマホに入れている形もいらっしゃるかなと思います
こういったものはメモリーにいる非常に簡単でベスト足といってまたそれをダブル
クリックだのなんか
選んねこう愚痴っちゃうとですねパッとこう再現してまた聞いたり見たりすることで時
動画もすぐ見ることができる
こういう格納してすぐに読み出してまた再現するとその対応の行法ですか非常に精緻
ですねそういったことがデジタルの得意技です
でアナログも音がするようにデジタルで基づく見合いの後じんを組んでそしてそれは
デジタルの得意技と組み合わされるこという
非常に
た大きなメリットを言いますそれがこの写真でうん
ご説明したいんですが例えばこれはですねコンサートの準備をしているところですが
真ん中に弊社のデジタル打ちさあがあります
今じゃあの音を混ぜるみっさーというのもデジタルで大きいものはみんな組まれてい
ます
自然的にあの先ほど申し上げたようにいろんな
missing エイジアの方が茶を行った調整とかフェーダーの音量のバランスと
そういった細かい情報は全部メモリーに入っていて
ワインクリップでボンド出てくるんですねそうするとおおおっ
動画家は万能が変わるから音が変わるとかね
演者が後動いたから音声が変わるとかあるいはいろんなことが放送プログラムでも
ライブコンサートでも
劇なんかでもうきますそういったものの仕事の設定というの全部個別にとっておいた後
で順番に再現しちゃえば
非常に難しい
yeah
ステージ上での濃そう外の操作ですねそういったムン
精緻に再現することができます
例えばシンセサイダー7日でもないことが言えて1曲1曲桜異色の設定も違いますし
また曲の中でもあのだんだん音が変わったりするわけですね
a メロと b メロではあの違うピアノてょなことをそういったことも皆
デジタルのメモリーに入れてすぐ読み出すことができる中メリットで
a サポートすることができるわけです
でそうすると自然とアナログの音がする
でもデジタルの音作りないを保存とていたし済むメリットが組み合わさってということ
ができてうんこ自信あって誘致イノベーションができたんじゃないかと僕は大金を持っ
ているんです
どうどういう意味かというですねイノベーションという言葉ですもともと技術
ダイハツとかそういう意味で使われていた言葉ですけども有名な経営学者の
クリステンセンて方が最近
イノベーションという言葉を再定義しています
どういう再定義をしたかというとええええ
犬異なる
自称を結びつけることで新しい価値観をもうとする発想法とか
a 考察とかそういったものをイノベーションと言うんですねそれが最近ここ56年
ですかね
のイノベーションという言葉の使い方になってきているんですけれども
それって要はあの
温故知新と僕に言わせれば同じでしてアナログの良さとデジタルの良さを結びつけて
新しい
温故知新の中で私たちは仕事をしていますと
自然とデータの与作が組み合わせることによってイノベーションのを着ていると
ですからまああの後高知市ニアリーイコーリノベーション
完全味言葉じゃないですね定義をビュー樹ですか
最近あのよく思うんですけど若い方がイノベーション大越こうしなきゃいけないと
すごく
a なんかいろんなところから言われているように感じます
ですから一生懸命なんか a というものを取り十分つもって一つ投げなきゃいけない
んじゃないかとこうなんか驚愕関連のように思われてるんじゃないかと思うんですが
別にそんなことをしなくてもいいんじゃないかと思うんですよね
要はあのー僕の例で言えば音の本質的な価値っていうのはどこにあるかっていうのは
アナログの時代に学んでいればそれデジタルの時代でもまた勝つことができた
そうやって私35年42食ってきたんですよ
だから本質的な価値観を手に入れることが一番足でそれによってもうずっとくれませよ
と
そういうことそれが私の言いたかったことです
いや最後に岩田氏がティムの音を色々
here なもので小さいもんで
でもおっがちょっとしんどいところすぐ取れ here
を
goo
ああああああああ
ni
re
goo
持った
[音楽]
多分
ワームのという
re おおおおう
angora
[音楽]
taloo
おっ
[音楽]
goo を
goo
うううう
[音楽]
道
4を
[音楽]
なりました